1227 ciel comme arena
j'ai créé le tournoi va commencer à
13h20 je vérifie tout est ok et je vais
attendre que vous arriviez petit à petit
je vais le lire dans le tchad est ce qu
on a déjà quelques inscrits 2 pour
l'instant c'est un tête à tête entre
notre ami suisse et une petite main
stream
alors je vous attends pendant ce temps
là on a le sélectionneur de l'équipe de
france
igor nataf qui en train de blitz est
alors j'imagine que courgettes avec deux
têtes est déjà pris je remets pas en
cause les compétences orthographique
[Musique]
d'igor je compte rencontrer un grand
maître américain prend donc très
américain d'ailleurs mais je ne connais
pas je tombe bouliac et alors est ce que
vous arrivez petit à petit n'hésitez pas
à me dire dans le chat à tagab
salut tagab salue le gaffeur bg ce que
vous allez bien est ce que le fait qu'on
soit samedi ça vous change un truc
puisque moi pas du tout cette base si
vous êtes nombreux à travailler encore
plus loin à aller au travail
ben écoute le gaffeur moi ça va toujours
la même vue sur le jardin des voisins
qui bronze mais je fais avec
alors commence dans 20 minutes à peu
près oui je ne vous êtes pas mal
d'étudiants aussi vous savez comment ça
va se passer
fait quoi toi le gaffeur obligé alors
que mathieu guignard s'est inscrit
edinson cavani la des personnalités pour
se teindra test d'anglais moi ça ça va
pas internet encore au moins sept gîtes
de l'accent l'accent français
généralement c'est pas notre rapport
salue pas qui tout film est ce que tu
fais partie de l'équipe bis trine
paquito ce que ce soir commence le top
12 des clubs online et je passe temps
entendu parler d'un crayon blisstree sa
lutte à vis de bruxelles à toute fraude
au difficile de ne pas parier sur sur
maxime quand même pour ce soir tu es
car toi même tu écoutes le confie on
devrait dire qu'on garde ça lui propose
un pas alors ce soir il ya seulement les
demi finales
moi j'imagine que vous êtes à peu près
tout ce gros ce gros événement profit de
médecins sans frontières
co-organisé kevin donc ça commencera à
19h avec une superbe opposition est le
numéro 1 tricolore qui sera la maxime
qui va jouer contre un tour de môle vab
libye et kevin est de s'ouvrir
si hockey france à parme
si serena n'a pas quittée en fait là je
vais à france des clubs
online qui va commencer ce soir
normalement sur les vrais clubs
d'un point de vue physique c'est à dire
je sais pas si tu joues à cannes s'est
toujours affichée par exemple et on a
sélectionné 12 équipes
j'ai vu qu'un petit souci de dernière
minute blue stream a créé une équipe du
coup joker de luxe
il habille joueurs par équipe et avoir
parlé plus haut niveau nous à la ferté
macé intéressante elle même format que
si une france notre team pérou team a
trottiné tout ça ça déjà participation
de match ça devrait être assez sympa
plusieurs samedi d'affilée c'est
intéressant mais ça joue ces bus qui
s'en occupe bien connaître alors que
lyon pouvait tomber paris ce qui est
sinon pour les places d'honneur alors le
problème de famé de kevin ce qui joue
contre maxime en demi-finale des chances
d'accéder à la finale
et moi je vais tenter de parier sur
mathieu entre etienne etienne et
à hyper à l'aise sur internet je trouve
au blitz il est beaucoup plus fort sur
un vrai chic et donc je vais jouer comme
la la petite surprise et a régné sur
mathieu oblige à la maxime grand
vainqueur je me mouille pas trop et
etienne au mont batch secondes le match
pour la troisième place
je sais pas s'il faut un match pour la
3e place derrière ça lui guillaume
paquito l'artiste d'abord c'est le gros
événement caritatif pour médecins sans
frontières je vais à trans des clubs ça
commence à 20h30 mais il ya déjà une
team qui est monté donc faut voir et que
celui qui s'en occupe c'est pas le droit
d'inscription vous êtes pour chivu dans
une charte ce soir d'ailleurs
du 3 + 0 1 ce soir donc je pense avoir
une grosse importance
évidemment pour maxime quelques avis là
beaucoup d'habitudes et aussi mais je
pense que peut-être le fait qu'ils
parlent d'un crémant ça peut jouer
vraiment des toits à mathieu etienne et
ouais je pense que mathieu il va sortir
des prépas de l'espace communal il a
pris ça sérieusement il en guise de le
faire le beau jeu là beaucoup de
supporters au match je vois dit sur
steam sur mathieu mises à part quelques
il sera là ce soir publicat n'alterne
pour le midi de salut ou ahmed et que
des supporteurs de match incroyable
pour l'instant il ya rigueur n'attache
pas si vous savez c'est laisser leur
équipe de france qui en train de jouer
la courgette 28 ou cybook à 7 13 ans
alors oui elle que contre mathieu quand
il était petit paquito celui qui prend
au g4 qui gagnera la richesse après je
le vois bien elles veulent jouer aux
cartes pour troller ajustements
certainement surtout s'ils mènent 60
rouleau de pq sur mathieu david roussel
prend des risques s'il me dit que
j'avais participé j'aurais sûrement
gagné elle c'est pour ça que je
participe pas d'ailleurs pour ne pas
être clip c'est les autres
alors qu'hier il nous dit qu'il ne
trouve pas la paix françois chess comme
quand ils trient par ouverture et ubi
gleut alors ça je ne sais pas après la
petrov vous s'appelait aussi la défense
russe je sais pas comment ça marche
exactement au blé ou devrait forcément
être répertorié quelque part peut-être
sous un autre nom du coup je sais pas
alors guillaume c'était sur quelles
parties de haendel la vidéo de call
mathieu qui est bien sûr un bordelais
pur souche grands supporters des
girondins battus corner je suis sûr que
calvin harris à lille va se préparer un
petit peu va toujours y vont tous se
préparent ils ont mis deux heures
même si l'enjeu c'est vraiment pour
médecins sans frontières pour faire un
truc sympa mais ça qu'ils ont envie de
faire une petite surprise et une partie
de nba la saison avec promotion qu'à
l'allier promotion cavale et ses
classiques
on est heureux quand on arrive à placer
une promo cavaliers donc blague à
hauteur de radoub dix mois mais après
seulement quatre joueurs c'est
difficile de prendre tout le monde déjà
ils ont pris cinq histoires de genève si
vous avez vu déjà peut être participé
pour certains d'entre vous hier il a
fait une simu talent de maxime sur les
fesses avec 25 joueurs et il y avait
loupé bikic l'ancien champion de tennis
qui participait qui a réussi à faire nul
contre maxime avec les noirs c'est assez
incroyable salué le gâchis d'un coup ça
va très bien et toi ce que tu joues les
tournois le gâchis est juste là pour
discuter avec nous passer un moment
tranquille
oui fm c'est à féminine basterds cw wgm
grands maîtres phil du nord fait me
signifiant maître fide salut marconnet
premier du nom puis à une dynastie
entière après toi marconnet oui oui tu
le seul et l'unique bar coup les second
et troisième sonde les projets merci au
festi lieu pour mettre le lien pour vous
inscrire
du coup il ya personne reste l'année de
la nouvelle bière bon après je sais
qu'il y avait beaucoup de candidats et
il a sélectionné que 25 joueurs allaient
être tiré au sort et le gâchis est bien
réfléchir quoi on a des joueurs d'échecs
pas comme dakar après le joueur de café
par excellence as well as fulda
simultanée pourtant elle a quand même un
peu circulé mais bon vu que c'était sur
lynch est peut-être que au moins parler
l'adami qui a fait nul contre lui baard
barbe de bronze bah dis donc pas bah
ouais spontanéité il a perdu une partie
quand même belle mais je crois que il y
avait vraiment des forces adversaires
j'ai pas suffire aux détails mais a déjà
y avait loupé bikic donc ça rigole pas
salut zégut hockey personne n'a été tiré
au sort de ce chat quoi je crie au
complot avec une hollandaise
en plus j'aime bien le en plus barbe de
monde le hollandais ça handicape du coup
ou pas de petrov et petrov en anglais
cette baie trois fois 6-1 des fois ça
peut certes au gafi avec 2 tf1 la
rigueur mais du coup ça devrait quand
même être disponible quelque part tu y
arrives pas trop d'explications est
bizarre ce qu'on peut voir les parties
de mvr certainement
tu vas sur lithium et que tu trouves le
pseudo de maxime vont pouvoir regarder
ce conte historique de partie après je
sais pas du tout si elle est un stream
la sève quelque chose ou quelqu'un doit
même pouvoir mater ça en replay je
branche mon ordi au passage pour éviter
cette en plein milieu du stream
et ouais tu veux bosser là petrov c'est
un bon conseil de franck zappa tu
regardes les parties de caruana qui
s'étaient préparés info là-dessus contre
40 cents images sur place du monde c'est
le spécialiste obtient je suis
directement les parties de famille et
même un article dans l'équipe en sur un
simultané de denzel bière ou du coup
c'est parce que parce qu'il ya des
boucheries kitsch qui jouer mais c'est
pas si souvent que les échecs sont à
l'honneur dans l'équipe
si vous voulez chercher je crois qu'il
ya une vidéo justement de la partie de
la mule du champion de tennis contre
maxime était très heureux proposé
d'ailleurs ses services en tant que
futur préparateurs et seconde en or pour
les candidats c'est maxime gagné pour
ensuite le jeu comme car cette musique
chez très très chaud est repris petit
prémat tennis a peut être pas ma avant
les parties
alors on va commencer dans cinq minutes
vous n'êtes pas beaucoup d'inscrits pas
ce qui se passe si peut-être que ce truc
ne s'actualise pas automatiquement
ah oui c'est ça un petit bug on a quand
même banane verte qui hélas maugrey
fallen oak est dj koze grob salut qu'à
cannes h 38
bégué ou du coup kalach tout court est
les prix et ce qui se passe avec la
kalach à l'écouté mitraillade 10
comprend la répétition en fait
alors j'utilise chez j'ai un peu honte
mais j'ai même pas de bases de données
sur mon ordi je ne prépare pas très
sérieusement je fais des tournois que je
joue par équipe je demande aux copains
de jeu picardie cinq minutes pour voir
ce que je joue mon adversaire au premier
coup et comme ça je peux faire ma prépa
et je dois dire comment éviter la
théorie le plus vite possible mais sinon
oui je te conseille bien sûr d'utiliser
à grosse mais mes gars basa 26 ça coûte
quand même assez cher de la mettre à
jour chaque année
gabla yan bin oui c'est sympa de stream
est d'être avec vous je débute mais
j'aime bien je vais certainement tribu
un peu plus aussi de deux piles ce parce
que pour l'instant je veux je ne joue
pas ne voyez pas tilté mais dès que je
visiterai un petit peu ça devrait
arriver à ça ne vous inquiétez pas il
faut la concurrence avec chamonix dakar
h ben j'espère que vous affronterez
peut-être dans cette arène je manquerai
pas ça ça lui l'aed
c'est quoi cette proposition beau jour
je veux faire et qui n'étaient pas avec
toi c'est vrai qu'on pourrait se poser
des questions ben avec plaisir un câble
à yann je ferai un petit stream va de
pédagogie quoi comme comme cabine fait
ça c'est vachement bien pour vous faire
progresser
je suis avec mes élèves de façon quelque
part donc le faire vraiment à grande
échelle et on à poupet poupe qui vient
de s'inscrire avec un drapeau des cils
canaille qui changent de nationalité
comme de chemise ali pou pi poupe
ils étaient mexicains ya deux jours
peut-être qu'il a un passeport spécial
qui lui permet de voyager
on commence pendant deux minutes à 1h20
saluer table du coup il ya du beau monde
one la concurrence pour balade verte les
mots greffe alive ou l'habitude de
batailler pour les deux premières places
alors on est samedi je sais pas ce que
ça change 6e
si pour certains d'entre eux on est
vraiment le week end
du coup ça modifie vous habitudes c'est
juste que le huitième jour de la semaine
mais on trouve quand même beaucoup de
pseudo habituel ouais je comprends que
tu puisses te croire mercredi
pakito je voudrais te cacher de vérifier
tous les jours en me réveillant quel
jour on est constante a abandonné
courgettes
c'est pas très très bien pour courgettes
au chômage technique
igor en attaque parce que c'est parce
qu'officiellement les olympiades ont été
annulés et reportés
c'était très peur en août mais j'imagine
qu'il ya très peu de chance pour faire
du jour voire 0 ouais je crois qu'on
perde tous un petit peu à la notion du
temps oui à ce rendez vous à 13 heures
tous les jours alors des sur battront
bec et
et je me rends compte ça a commencé ou
pas ça a commencé
ça a commencé avec poux qui boucle entre
eux inna aide pour le premier choc de
cette arène gamme gardeur dayan font bip
ou cabanes plus de 2600 qui part assez
largement favori de ce tournoi mais ou
pis poupe
on sait que c'est un petit peu une
machine at-il donc il suffit qu'ils
perdent une partie que tout s'enraye
je ne souhaite pas évidemment ya saïdou
bâ triche date fiche vaut mieux que je
parle un petit peu anglais quand même
parce que je suis amené assez souvent à
traduire des articles où allait réécrire
avec quelques répétitions au moins
possible autant jouer qu'une ou deux pas
plus ok poupe hip hop un droit mais
peut-être que tu vas te laisser
entraîner alors du coup tu te fais
attaquer en tout cas donc c'est les
noirs qui seront attaqués
c'est typique un comble quand
l'adversaire développe son foie ancien
ghetto ici et rock de ce côté là on va
souvent essayé d'éliminer le défenseur
pour ensuite créer un petit peu un
gruyère sur 15 noir attaque avec le pur
h et aussi stands à ouvrir la colonne h
le plan bête et méchant c'est de manger
en j'essaie d'ouvrir la couleur d'âge et
d'intérêts d'amour ashes pour webmasters
achète moi je suis donc certainement y
rentrer qui poussent parfois on peut s'y
sacrifier la qualité mais ici pour
cavaliers prend à chaque alerte tout à
fait ok pour les droits y'a pas de g4
nous faut contrôler
avec une bonne défense je pense qu'il ya
neuf il est objectivement mieux ici
après c'est du bliss donc d'un point de
vue pratique il va faire un renvoi
quelle attaque quand même aller assez
vite on va voir ce que ça donne et
qu'elle éprouve à chuck en manque et
d'ahmed fit m&f août plutôt pas mal joué
il va ramener sa dame affirme qu eto
pour défendre son roi maintenant le
danger serait de jouer tours géantes et
4 mais y aurait un cavalier qui pourrait
s'en crée wild cat et bloqué un petit
peu l'attaqué des blancs salut gens fous
de la donne et salute mont-ngafula je
suis leader j'arrête vous à bas par
exemple toujours arrêtée au sommet et
ouais je vois bien le lien pour vous car
le salut zazou on voit que quand même
qu'ils jouent très très vite par rapport
à son adversaire
on à rennes c'est vraiment important
c'est en tout cas qui visent les
premières places dans magazines et les
parties
moi j'avais plutôt bien et pas pour
l'instant l'attaquent bush a échoué et
il ya quand même une grosse faiblesse en
d3 ici et en plus en plus malgré tout
donc certes ils ont un peu plus sur la
colonne h ça manque de pièces pour poopy
poupe
je pense que la pression sur detroit les
plus importantes n'a pas vraiment le
temps de l'attaqué alors y avait
sûrement enlever sa dame pour défendre
le pion avec la tour mais ici car mon
c'est gros avantage noir ça reste
largement retournable surtout pour
acrobat com poopy poupe
ce que je connais un joueur surnommé the
watcher oui je vois bien une petite rue
parallèle kashi parce que j'ai joué sur
place est au tout début
celle d'amener beaucoup il était très
souvent connectés sur ce site je vois
énormément et je n'étais pas très pas
très poli pas très tard peut non plus
pas très bon perdant patrick fouques
quoi de bonne chère je sais pas
peut-être il a évolué depuis mais je
n'ai pas trop fan du personnage c'est
plus signé jean homme du match
pendant ce temps poopy poupe il a perdu
t3 comme prévu le problème de manger hs
et juste avec le noir on est très
heureux de donner notre dame pour les
deux tours derrière la dame blanche sera
impuissante à mettre en danger trois ici
l'avantagé un peu creusé par là les
prêts à laisser achètent parce que tout
parce qu'il ya du tour d adam prend f3
karim beaucoup plus dangereux ynet qui
fait une grosse partie avec les noailles
s'est pas laissée bluff pour qu'ils
coupent pourrait chuter d'entrée du coup
tu connais un petit peu et 4
je connais un petit peu on parle de lui
j'avais pas parents qu'il avait estimé
pour les deux chaises bras mais après
l'épisode dont je t'ai parlé sadate
vraiment dizaine d'années donc de l'eau
a coulé sous les ponts n'a plus qu'une
vente
elle va voir s'ils arrivent à se montrer
précis jusqu'au bout puisque pour
l'instant je pensais la partie quasi
parfaite
la deux pour le plus alors là il ya une
vraie menace de tout reproche est parce
que l arrivée il y aura dans le premier
set puis poupe qui essaie de jouer des
pratiques ladakh et les pions peut-être
qu'il va se lasser de tenter la chose
que m6 ne va maintenant avec des deux
pions avec les avec les blancs en plus
du troisième pour hachette il met un
quatrième elle craquait alors ça reste
très difficile de mobiliser ses pions
pour l'instant il y aura des réseaux de
père pète de partout f3 est faible aussi
c'est une position souvent se conclure
par par des chèques perpétuelle mais
avec avec la pompe dieu assez confiant
pour beaucoup plus tôt que maintenant
ils action j'ai passé et inna est requis
a donné une tous ses pions un par mois
c'est fort une dame c'est beaucoup trop
fort diva attention là je pense qu'il a
fait une erreur en dedans et d'échecs en
c3 ce que maintenant il s'est fait
couper son roi et du coup il s'est mis
dans un réseau de perpétuels impossible
à briser donc l'échec en c3 est ce
qu'ils découvrent ces rares il fallait à
tout prix avoir la possibilité de
s'échapper avec son roi non normalement
je vois pas comment il pourrait éviter
la nuit siècle et blanc en plus il elle
il est remonté à 33 secondes
salut la capote masqué est ce que tu
joues cette fois ci mais samedi
peut-être que t'as pas de pas de taf la
crac haddaway alors tu avais regardé une
vidéo de lui disons que l'ouverture de
ne pas dire en tenir une vertu et
efficace en petit rapide à leucate cinq
dames à chaque mois je la connais comme
attaque d'un cas moi parce que c'est un
petit peu lui qui a développé sa
on voit très bien ce que c'est vrai
votre ennemi est ce que c'est parce que
j'avais regardé avec des élèves en fait
c'était bien je leur apprenais quand il
faisait des tournois scolaires mais là
c'était vraiment pour un niveau très bas
ont gagné le plus souvent nos partie
grâce aux coups illégaux
donc du coup je vous conseille pas
vraiment au delà de 1200 retraite ou
version je crois pas du tout le 400 m à
c'est facile d'égaliser avec les doigts
et même en général de prendre en otage
un livre sur l'anglais était et a joué
un livre sur les anglaises la capote
masquer ce n'est pas une bonne idée
je vais attendre dormir au bout de trois
pages je pense vraiment que tu devrais
jouer tu pourras peut-être verte ils
dépouillent à 2600 ça vaut le coup je
parle pour éviter le père pète qui poupe
il prend des risques il prend des
risques avec sa dame après c'est pareil
qu'edouard pour tout vérifier les cases
des chèques pour pas perdre une tour sur
une double attaque
voilà tout simplement d'un projet 3
mercier les deux joueurs qui sont
complètement aveuglé en fait mais par
chance ou pas quand même gagné quand
même gagner la tournée eu un gros un
gros bug mutuelle après dun contre tous
c'est pas si facile à gagner alors en
l'occurrence là la tour est vraiment mal
placé donc du coup ça devrait aller
parce que vraiment on peut voir sur la
bande directement voilà tout est coupé
nos classes amat c'est facile mais dans
les faits remplies si le roi au mieux
des chics avec la tour c'est vraiment
pas pas évident
[Musique]
elle est on va regarder le gaffeur fou
en train de dégâts le gars fort fouquet
toujours au rendez vous salut le futur
talent pour le lien l'anglais smeia
auvergne cependant dit la capote masque
c'est un petit peu plus être l'organe
anglaise
à mon humble avis on sait qu'à 2,5 g 4
alaric par la capote maskin salluste eh
ben ça dépend de ton style je sais pas
trop si dans le jeu excellent pourquoi
pas mais c'est plutôt quelqu'un de
d'agressive d'amis qui jouent pour
l'initiative leur plaît c'est être pas
l'idéal
je ne sais pas je n'ai pas trop vu comme
le riz 10 aces et souple barbarian one
je parle pas non plus hein quand j'ai
les blancs j'ai bien évidemment on tient
bon match et les blancs tout de suite en
le centre je vais pour initiative n'est
pas assez sur une partie car rien à voir
avec la reine qui s'est lancé tout seul
où je vais perdre on va vous dire avec
vous avec tombeur de dans le ton bien
plus tôt il a fini par perdre gil
tombeur parce qu'ils étaient
complètement gagnant du coup je pensais
qu'il allait le battre poupinel qui
jouent contre manu guignard essaie de se
rattraper de tout ce prix là 800 points
de plus il a déjà mangé une pièce s'est
mal passé ce qui s'est passé pour ma
porte est ouverte sur le plus en plus à
la mode dans la taxe pour acheter direct
surtout nous l'avions de kétou on envoie
ses petits bras avec les blancs et
comment il a perdu une pièce manu et
s'il s'était passé
ces prix des cinq éliminations du
défenseur lecavalier n'ont même pas
hélas juste juste donné son ok là
généreusement donnés sont fous et là il
devrait abandonner peu retardé un petit
peu grâce à ce courage mais il est comme
complètement foutue ici on va voir si tu
comprend un truc en regardant ouais j'en
doute et ça qu on s'en doute mais tu
peux de choisir on tourne avec john
anthony ça faisait trop de com arena
pour lui ça lui donne-t-il chez merci
l'ouverture vannes dit ça me fait
davantage pour un truc à une ouverture
des chèques mais j'avais vraiment pas
cavalier c3 avec cette appellation
pourquoi n'est-elle pas plus utilisé
bon à cause d'un déplacement ces trois
vannes en fait ben si je pense que c'est
pas une fellation soin de sortir son
canalisations c3 le poète principal
c'est juste que en parlent sont tout de
suite donc tu laisses noir la
possibilité de jouer par exemple 500
cavaliers c'est trois premiers coups et
d'égaliser directement en fait déjà
tellement dur d'obtenir un petit
avantage avec les plantes sont tous un
peu un coup trop neutre tout de suite
notre adversaire égalise et pendant ce
temps manu manu se fait maths et ben tu
m'as nuit selon matt et de partout à
dire que la son roi et bien confinés
dans le petit coin a pas d'échappatoire
neil qui finit la partie comme avec plus
de temps qui va commencer
c'est impressionnant varga
des marques ou des premiers sa petite
main vitrine qui jouent contre j'aime mu
où il est sûrement né en 2003 qui a créé
son pseudo en 2003 fait une sacrée
différence d'âge
ouais apparemment la vidéo la partie aux
maximes fait des promotions cavaliers
date celle ci contre outre bob fontaine
elle est très jolie sont maxime c'est un
habitué à des prix de modèle cette fois
comme est née quand je suis né en 1986
le 8 août
le même jour que rogers fait d'ailleurs
vous êtes jaloux et vit à 2003 qui fit
le pleutre la capote basket c'est bien
aussi j'imagine un jeune sourd du coup
je regarde pas du tout la partie hélas
terminée avant même qu'on ait pu
vraiment s'y intéresser puisque là je
pense que c'est matt imparable va pas de
défendre sur se plonger si ça vient
wife's est né voit f7 la dame trois
films at simplement book la double
menace ici
marcoux ne se passe pas bien pour
marconnet en apparaît une dent apparaît
2 mais il n'a pas paraître ouailles adam
g7
du coup c'est matt oui c'est de trouver
une partie est à son commencement avec
un peu de chance
voilà on navigue plus entre tata chante
pas dit plus
je vois souvent aussi dans cette arène
oui les pièces de la merde nous disent
t'aime je te laisse m de telles paroles
avec les pions peut-être une très belle
partie
un joueur d'options très belles parties
de deuxième heure diemer ni dans les
chicken qui a joué des 18 premiers coûte
une partie avec uniquement ses pions
c'est une partie correcte contre un fort
joueur en plus vous pouvez la trouver en
la cherchant bien
donc google assez facilement je me suis
rapidement son attrait pour sa belle et
très amusante
une exception dumas méprise complètement
et je pense que ce soit 18 coups il a un
seul qui a un patron correct d'après
l'ordre si nous tournent toujours bon
dos est long zimmer écrit comme ça c'est
lui qui a inventé le gambit blacks marc
diab heures si tu tapes un truc du genre
deuxième heure oms game quelque chose
comme ça
aisheen pony games sas un peu se
trouvait en cinq minutes tu cherches un
petit peu en fait le sac on change de
parti à chaque fois l'arrêt nature une
arène bien en soi mais elle m'intéresse
à toujours aller jusqu'à ce que je
regarde aussi le chat développer son
envoi sur un concept en tonnes mais
avant la finale
tu me conseilles bagan moment tu ne
diras si tu trouves un tel talent 21 je
me souviens qu'on prononce comme ça vous
faites partie très équilibrée ce nom de
ce que j'aperçois est un pur le plus
pour les blancs ceci dit mais à quelques
compensations sais pas si clair la paire
de fou est plutôt sympa pour les noirs
ces deux est faible le voit remettre un
peu affaibli en reprenant avec g ok il
va bien il se verrait bien avec les
noirs tata qui va 400 points deux points
est ce que vous ferez sinon on va
laisser la place peut-être dans la
colonne chez pour les pièces lourdes
nouvelle prouve que ces pièces c'est de
la merde
10h32 or c'est magnifique
ouais ça c'est une autre partie de jean
meyer de légende c'est pas celle de
tokyo où elle se termine aussi par là
nul je vous sais pas plus
les faciles à trouver si vous tapez pas
juste que vous à 10 toof c'est très une
beauté surpris deux botteurs mettre
leurs pièces seront prises à tour de
rôle est là c'est magnifique pour les
puristes un mot je vous la recommande
bien jouer marconnet vous me direz vous
avez le temps de regarder la partie vite
fait ce que vous en pensez mais c'est
assez déstabilisant de voir tous ces
coups de pied ces courants d'air cet
espace gigantesque devant nos pièces ne
pas l'utiliser
ah bah oui ça va sacrifier des pièces
niveau pratique sont tous envie de ça
peut être bien par exemple le gambit
halloween
si tu vois ce que c'est quand même assez
populaire avec à cause d'une bombe ça
marche très bien mais man party classics
à sainte maxime jouer le gambien l'oin
je me souviens d'un darty qu'il ya
quelques mois il avait repris plein de
plans de bliss de maxime sur le gambit
halloween où il mate et ses adversaires
avec le roi qui se baladait qu'ils aient
tous le temps d'échiquier pourquoi je
pense que l'anglais des pleutres bat
déjà l'anglais par définition une fille
sinon l'idée c'est quand même de jouer
tranquillement sur l'aide de sortir son
fois offert une quête au de mettre une
petite pression à long terme stratégique
je ne vise pas le roi avec l'anglais
soit pas du tout à part peut-être sur
certaines variantes squash cartes etc
mais ça c'était pas l'onglet the les
puristes mais après bien sûr c'est un
style qui peut être efficace
la juge excellente arrêts du monde de
suture j'ai pas mieux teddy bear et qui
a fait un tacle le talent tu tues et ce
dès mardi première ronde j'ai vu il a
réussi à faire nul entre autres marie
zweig sûr qu'ils jouent bien mais
c'était amusant il a déjà gravi petit
fils a réussi à forcer la nulle même
dans un blitz anecdotique
du coup tu peut revendre ton bouquin la
capote masqué vérifier les répertoires
de guérilla ht1a est sûr qu'il a jamais
joué l'ouverture vie plus lui qui est un
petit peu en bois de bouleaux ton même
si on a des fous de couleurs opposées ce
qui favorise grandement les chances 2
nuls en finale ici
quatre points c'est beaucoup j'ai déjà
été nulle une fois et quatre pions
demi-finale de [ __ ] couleurs opposées
mais vraiment il les avait aligné pour
que je fasse un blocus parfait donnait
beaucoup beaucoup aidé mon adversaire
jorge chinois qui s'appelait lily c'est
pas une blague ça je m'en rappelle
d'ailleurs j'étais très heureux d'avoir
fait nul en une centaine de coups et que
mes quatre poumons
ouais du coup c'est un peu en mode
séries tu m'as fait honneur dans ta
partie se trouve tu as dû jouer un black
barre du coup j'ai raté ça
le système bobigny qui est un peu ras
avec des pions centraux c4 des trois ou
quatre d'accord mais c'est pas la
pareille en beauce revienne et que
justement qui est censé égalisé avec les
avec les noirs peut-être je confond le
charmant par un spécialiste de l'ong
l'aise à barbarian arjel hall à marianne
qui a déjà gagné cette année plusieurs
fois peut-être
elle est souvent dans les premières
places il a une qualité de moi mais on a
trois kilos secondes
il veut s'infiltrer du rallye menaces
mat tout est contrôlé les menaces dame
j'évite damache 8 et bas salaires
particulièrement puissant je vois pas
d'autres moyens pour parer le mal si que
de sacrifier la dame en g2 ont dévié la
tour permettra de s'échapper bien du
coup si on doit jouer d'alger de autant
dire que c'est foutu et l'abandonnent il
abandonne alors bien trouver peut-être
pipe ou pour voir si il a joué blackmar
son adversaire a refusé à mon âge ou un
gambit halloween où je vous parle tout à
l'heure ça c'est vraiment le bourg dont
il voulait faire un environnement fait
son adversaire dragon's refuse
j'écris là je vais cavaliers pourquoi f
cell ça c'est un coup de beats agathe
pour le sacrifier juste pour des rockets
c'est un échec
vous avez un pion à vii j'ai pas quel
est le monde
deux bandits lumière nous qui existe en
droit carrière en russie siakam
d'options je pense que dans la pratique
ce n'est pas si mal pour les blancs
april a réussi cammas partiront
qu'artificielle dragotto cissé a réussi
c'est quand même le bout de je veux à
tout prix que seront à reste au milieu
de l'échiquier et il a eu peur ils
avaient peur juste il a très bien
calculé que derrière il y avait une
découverte et un double échec pensions
pas prendre la tour du groupe et
attaque c'est beau ce qu'il veut dans la
connerie rend le matériel pour attaquer
à son tour du coup il fait réfléchir
puberg a plus qu'une minute
c'est lui qui se retrouve finalement
avec son rôle de tel est pris qui
croyait prendre
parti dans l'esprit on pas grand chose à
vérifier ce que voulait dire à granby
granby n'a aucune connotation sexuelle
ça q games par contre le roi blanc est
quand même un petit peu trop et ici je
suis très inquiet pour pompiers poupe
il réfléchit du dragão où il tombe sur
ce coup ça fait un moment déjà que la
position est compliqué doit calculer de
tours f2 il le joue l'extrait leroy et
joue simplement maintenant on va finir
le développement aller plus loin comme
plus mais le roi en des trois écoles un
petit peu inquiétant alors fou et 3
c'est peut-être pas si grave
cavalier bleu 4 j'aime pas trop infocom
développer cette pièce pour qu'hypo pas
c'est le rudiments jouer avec tous ces
pièces finir son développement qui
reviennent aux fondamentaux pukki poupe
sacrifice de pions et parfois d'autres
pièces n'est ce pas systématique
alors les pièces on va les échanges et
on va manger une pièce contre une pièce
de même valeur sera pas un sacrifice
un sacrifice c'est quand on donne la
pièce montre pas grand chose dans des
champions comme quand on sacrifie sur un
hôtel un truc pour les dieux y a rien en
échange
si on espère quoi autant dire que rien
ouais il a raté cavaliers v5 ici c'est
est-ce que c'était mat
non c'était pas mal mais qui dit elle a
lieu son cas
ton g2 roi 3 way
nous sommes très mal se passer pour le
roi blanc je vois palmade des trains
pour la dame d'abel 5 ont menacé d'un
mètre quatre matches prises la marque à
3-2 trois tours du but
ça ça devait gagner du coup on avait
quoi vous offre 4 contres et la case on
met deux races l'élection
le roi est quand même toujours
extrêmement faible du cavalier b4g 13 ça
marche avec des plaies cinq tu envoies
cette fois ya dame pro b 4 et après on
va voir damas trois sur moi ici c'est
qu'on a du fleuve de galère de gagner
aussi
donc je pense qu'il y en a partout oui
siens faut voir cahier des gardes c'est
pas évident la plus grosse seconde peut
se retourner alors il a pris en d4 doit
peut-être gagner aussi avec la même idée
je pense dans le bessin qui libérait
cette diagonale pour la dame et
maintenant vous élève de tourcoing 4
gagne peut-être aussi il faut calculer
ses faux airs de me paraît tout simple
mais à tour deux tours de 2.4 c'est un
classique des villans pas la protection
ça se voit gagner aussi alors qu'est-ce
qu'il va jouer la joue et un bébé 4 il
n'a pas toi un coup trop chaude du tout
et manon fouet 5 ça ça permet de
protéger cette colonne
et peut-être silva son sang il a gagné
autant à gagner autant ils regagnaient
la cpc ou prend 1,5
il a donné sa dernière a complètement
paquet dragone il avait un petit peu
roulé tous les thèmes tactique qui
marchait pour lui il a choisi de donner
sa lame
c'est la panique ok pompiers poubelles
écoute merci d'avoir fait le spectacle
et bonne chance pour comprendre voici de
trouver deux parties aussi animé j'ai
pas pu balade verte encore alors en plus
on est en chocolat à c'est un derby ça
mais classique
un clasico de notre aréna banane verte
moquerait fu lei qu'est ce que ça donne
ma première vue les blogs les retiennent
pas mal égalité matérielle mais un
cavalier très fort les pièces mineurs
noirs sont plutôt dominé la seule
colonne ouverte est contrôlé par les
blancs là des faiblesses
donc ici je pensais difficile pour
mauvais faux l'oeil mais derrière n'y
fait malgré tout défoncer passive robin
stature d'un cinquième ce qu'ils
découvrent la complexité du jeu c'est
bien
non mais il faut pas rester bloqué sur
sur la pleutrerie de ce que j'ai dit la
capote masqué juste ça juste parce qu'on
ne puisse pas le roi lors de vos âmes
être un grand rôle sur une anglaise le
but juste quand même de mater doux sur
l'anglais l'on va gagner mais souvent on
va mettre longtemps puis honda
ighirri je voulais jouer l anglaise donc
à j'enlève l'évaluation et si vous
voulez que ça ne décale pardon m
l'émulation c'est la barre sur le côté
celle du pierrot alors banane verte qui
met toujours la pression ici sur un
progrès mais il se bat bien avec les
doigts c'est durant ce fou on a vraiment
du mal à refaire quelque chose il est
tellement dominé par ce cavalier malgré
tout concrètement c'est pas si facile
pour les blancs alors pour moi c'est la
défense du cours des 5
mais ce qu'on aimerait bien s'activer
sur le kotel est ce que on peut pas
sacrifier justement des cinq parfois
pour jouer tour j'ai trois jeux c'est
par ici que dans ma canne bien se
débarrasser de deux mois une paire de
tours l attaque à 4 elle contrôle la
colonne c'est très désagréable n'est
vraiment réduit à une passivité totale
bat nos tours g3 je pensais pas mal pour
attaquer il faut vous occupera de plomb
des cinq plus tard
bon j'ai 3 qui a été joué j'aime bien
qu'amélie g6 ici avec des jus de se
retrouver contre le cavalier
complètement dominant donc le fou dans
son coin et alberti qui m'écoutent salut
de six salles utilisera et pense qu'elle
n'est pas la dalle terme puisqu'elle
sera là ce soir à 19h où le super
événement caritatif avec médecins sans
frontières avec maxime mathieu fabre
etienne bacrot
ça spoile à partir en direct le dernier
dessin ne l'avait jamais fait 10 des
voix l'anglais c'est plutôt une
ouverture bien réputé la capote masquer
cette ouverture fiable du tout va sur
l'ouverture solide sérieuse
c'est un coup alternatif 1.4 dgac malgré
tout mais c'est bien sûr tout à fait
jouable
c'est plus souvent pas l'armé principale
dans le joueur de top niveau mais plutôt
quelque chose qui va faire de temps en
temps pour changer mais après oui des
joueurs des grands maîtres spécialiste
de l'anglais était sont mon rêve bertoua
et kachi avec les blu c'était quand même
un joueur de blackburn gamer jusqu'à ce
que je me prenne que des prépas donc du
coup j'ai dû arrêter un petit peu de
gambie t impunément et je joue de quatre
salles est à peu près là le 4 et je le
vois ce qui se passe souligne des petits
trucs pas trop jouer je mets un flou
ambiant le ghetto et puis ensuite vous
le partie d'échecs avec les noirs je
joue j'ai six coups g7
quelles que soient les coups adverses
héros suis m'adapte je l'aï eu six des
six c5 pareil on évite un petit peu la
théorie alors va lancer notre parti
nasa joue entre ces menaces ne reste
plus que des pièces lourdes ici et en
plus pour les noirs je voulais jouer
arthur que j'aime pas c'est à dire l ont
pas de nom mais ouverture refusé par la
barre qu'est ce que tu aimes pas qu'il
arabe ou explicite à panser cette plaie
ne peut pas aimer ou ne pas aimer le
beau jeu je me fais que du beau jeu
alors tactique adaptée emprise ok
c'était bien calculer mais là maintenant
et adama chis et malheureusement pour le
cavalier semi cavaliers sont rois qui se
retrouve en grand danger lorsqu'elle a
un gros avantage avec son tube pas à
cela il n'y a pas de moyen de défendre h
alors peut-être que le roi pourra
trouver un peu à l'abri au sens dès que
c'est pas si grave mais où est le
problème si ça va être de tout mettre
sur et 7 est alors certes les plans des
pions en moins mais ils ont une
forteresse autour de l'envoi alors je
pense que l'échec en la chute par contre
c'est une grosse erreur de sa zone c'est
un petit peu faire échec pour faire
échec
ça n'a pas grande chose on se retrouve
avec la de m'attaquer une paire un temps
alors vraiment la pression elle était
sûre ce cloaque cette discipline est un
petit peu en arrière ou illustrait je
pense que juste un coup comme je sais
pas pour être 4 peut défendre une fois
ci ont des fois une fois déjà on peut
ramasser la tour et cette enfilade et
même au pire juste jouer double est une
pièce est ici va tomber et c'est le
dernier rempart pour le roi donc les
blancs auraient une attaque décisive il
a fait échec à tel qu annoncé le petit
pion des deux qui essaie de trouver du
contre je meurs attention mesdames c'est
cet échec
et si le roi reculions ramat du couloir
il parle de ce côté là
pas que ce soit la meilleure des idées
même que la grotte ah ouais mais là
c'est un petit peu extrêmes comme
philosophie avec les noirs tu fais
comment du coup atteint un répertoire
beaucoup plus étoffé que moi elle catchy
bas ce match avait un peu des katas
permettra sûrement de progresser dans le
sens où tu t'habitues rader type de
position différente nous stratégiquement
on va il y aura d'autres enjeux le fait
de jouer les deux coups je pensais bien
pour la progression même si au niveau
des résultats tu risques de perdre des
partis au début parce que tu sortiras ta
zone de confort
après sa demande aussi un gros travail
d'apprentissage de théorie si tu veux
jouer une grande ligne sur des 4 es
tellement de choses à apprendre
faut être motivé ce roi qui voyage vous
rappelle qu'il vient de 2 g 8 dates qui
a sacrifié sa place où il espère
récupérer une autre action qui ont des
deux malheureusement pour lui là c'est
bien joué ces quatre ils attaquent à la
fois la tour et le tube récupérer le
c'est un danger surtout en fait ce qui
compte y lisent les blancs certains mots
ce roi séverin construit son abri sera
jamais harcelé d'échec dans vingt mots
ici il n'ya plus qu'à une affaire de
technique
rosa zoom oms quoi jouer f4 on doit
jouer f4 je pense que c'est illégal
la capote masquer la scandinave c'est
parce que vous regardez kevin les
italiens la sicilienne sauf la méthode
mise évidemment
évidemment on n'a même pas besoin de
préciser genre d'autres choses elle 5
l/100km 5 c c'est la hollandaise qui à
la mode chez les français c'est maxime
lagarde qui la joue beaucoup jules
moussard donc les plus jeunes fort
français le d'aficionados de hollandaise
moi je suis assez heureux avec les
blancs quand on joue au f5 sur des
quatre nages le fou j'ai 5 au deuxième
coup et sur cavani apsys manger tout de
suite en m6 pour détériorer la structure
et jouer sur les cartes blanches mais
fait la hollandaise louis sa mâchoire au
moins c'est pas pleutre clairement c'est
le bout je veux déséquilibré tout de
suite la position avec les noirs c'est
un peu l'idée
quitte à prendre le risque d'être moins
bien au moins on aura créé un
déséquilibre
on pourra plus facilement jeu mais pour
le gain réel semble un système avec g3
très bons résultats
bahia commandes plein d'armes possibles
après à bien son fond sur le gâteau
c'est rarement mauvais toute façon c'est
pas moi qui vous diraient contraire est
apte à jouer les scandinaves même allons
distribuer en tenue c'est l'école eric
priet ceux qui connaissent grands
maîtres français spécialiste des parties
à la veulent dire d'experts de la
scandinave
j'apprends c'est un petit peu à tout son
club à carcassonne
si vous jouez un jour contre 1 2 joueurs
de
carcassonne d'un carcassonnais faut être
sûr qu'ils jouent à la scandinave
je vous tous ça rigolait matches par
équipe à aligner les chics et les uns à
côté des autres dans notre camp on joue
tous eu quatre en face on a que du d5
comment on peut oublier avec plier à
galtier alors avec les bruits gallas
avait un petit moment qui dans cette
finale mais ils bougent les pions c'est
normal ça prend du temps
la dame normalement elle va contrôler
sans problème le cube et on aura juste
avant de faire une deuxième avec le
cloud h la fusée h puis s'il ya quand
même des thèmes parce que la tour est
pour l'instant très éloignée du roi on
peut facilement créer des menaces de
double échec pour la mode j'aime c'est
ce qui fait tout de suite je pense qu'il
va le voir quand même ça ne mérite ici
même si le voit ce n'est pas si facile à
pareil mois car en achetant il a raison
c'est la gaze la plus hype on va essayer
d'aller cueillir ses pions
dany et du coup est ce que ça te fait
progresser maintenant tu vois plein de
nains oublié sur la scandinave
bonne vidéo on va manger à vii peut-être
non nous azou il aura pris son temps
quand même pour gagner cette partie
j'ai l'impression que ça fait très
longtemps qu'elle dure ya une dame de
plus depuis trop de co2 si ça vous ans
adam de plus pour comprendre non les
tellement gagnant groupe pire si ça se
passe mal et pour a sacrifié sa dame sur
le pion est là avec trois pions lier la
seule tour sera complètement inefficace
avec le roi éloignait pour défendre
il y avait pas vraiment la prison
hashtag puisqu'il y aurait eu un double
échec
là c'est ce qui se passe dans mon
premier 2 c'est bien c'est le plus
facile même si l'a pas poussé en fait le
clou dans le bon sens
il a réussi à bâle a gagné la réussir à
ne pas la gagner ici avec les blancs
fallait-il plongé en elle parce que là
tout était derrière le clou watch et
maintenant ben on attend grâce et à ste
marie suis juste à temps dans la colonne
h ce qui fait dame va manger
derrière bougera l'autre pionts même à
lui le rabat sera tranquillement et si
on fait pas là me fait quoi si on fait
roi f7 si on peut juste attendre en fait
avec le noir le plus on peut jamais
avancer parce qu'il ya pour pro achète
c'est pareil on sacrifie on gagne lui
du coup c'est nul et ils ont fait de
cette façon donc avec sa femme de plus
d'assaut
réussi à ne pas gagner j'ai vraiment
tout fait elle mangeait tous les pions
ça c'est incroyable je viens terrain
missclick participer à ces brillants
du coup je fais jouer une partie outre
au bal trompette
hp s'est encore jamais arrivé
le mystique participation vous n'êtes
pas mentir mais mouvante urnes 14 je me
fais des trop sur cases noires sciemment
tempier vient de faire tomber un pierrot
pense du 3 + 2 elle une petite incrément
normalement pour survivre global
trompait je sais pas si tu m'écoutes
mais si c'est le cas et c'est de ne pas
me faire tilter s'il te plaît là pour ma
première partie alors c'est vraiment
d'essayer de gagner ce pur et simple de
mettre la pression ou au pire des quatre
joueurs 6h va être très heureux de
manger le case noire doit reprendre de
la dame à tout prix pour défendre son
option comme que je fasse attention à
pas me faire mater ça m'est déjà arrivé
à d'autres genres de variantes
là j'ai la possibilité de jouer à 9,6
ouvrir la diagonale
je pense y être pleutre en jouant dame b
6 cavaliers celsis d'ailleurs
j'ai joué à elle 6 j'ai vraiment envie
d'ouvrir ligne pour me fous alors en
aucun cas je vais donner mon fou par
exemple pour essayer un pion il est
beaucoup trop important ici c'est de
calculer cavaliers absent tu vois pas
trop où il met sa d'amour f4 mais je
crois qu'il va avoir un gros point sur
ce cavalier
même si j'arrive pas à gagner je pense
sur dernière 4 je vois pas dams et 7
pour le tourin je vois pas de découverte
décisive ici pour moi
on sent qu'il ya quelque chose pourtant
27 en plus je me prendrais cavaliers
projet si ce serait une mauvaise
nouvelle
[Musique]
est-ce que cavaliers des six à assez
fort ici j'attaque j'attaque plein de
trucs en même temps mais de manière un
peu miraculeuse tout est défendu il
devrait y avoir un moyen de gagner un
truc
j'arrive à être malin mais ça c'est pas
gagné
lord ahmed 6 encore bouger les cavaliers
papa comment gagner une pièce on a
l'impression que ça apporte tellement je
me développe des aléas kg 4 j'avais pas
vu un très grave au piège aurait elle
changé les dames nuit des fantômes
défend tout et quand je parle beaucoup
que je suis extrêmement longs aussi
cavalier 4 a l'air pas mal
l'idée c'est que s'ils mangent
je vais reprendre en attaquant son
cavalier qui le défenseur du tube et
donne ici mange pas je vais juste manger
en c3 et à mal se passer pour sa
structure en fois schiste est un échec
en fait qui servait pas à grand chose je
pense bêtement aux sphères hôtel 4
étoiles
moi j'aurais participé à cette arène
j'aurais fait le nombre
alors il a pris donc là bas ne m'a pas
trop oui il va faire pour régler ce
problème a pris les pas de solution je
pense qu'il ya quatre étaient justes
gagnon autant qu'ils sont fous sera en
l'air à la fin de la variante ici donc
va pas de solution pour lui sinon c'est
barbarian qui en tête devant des vues
lues et bananes vertes paquito et 4g le
droit auquel j'ai eu droit qu'à huit sur
huit sont jours à cannes j'ai le droit
alors il tente de contre-attaquer au bal
trompette mais c'est pas très grave je
vais justement j'ai je lui hissé de
l'eau à je pourrais vraiment être
extrêmement pleutre en échangeant les
dames mais je vais quand même manger f2
j'ai envie d'être le train d'un prêt à
donner une mauvaise image de moi pour me
prendre les changes les dames ce qui les
maths en c2 alors il menace quand même
de m'embêter on peut vraiment juste un
peu parce que j'ai la tour qui peut
revenir défendre sans trop de problèmes
mon seul souci c'est de développer mon
fou j'ai un petit peu de mal à
développer ce fou et du coup j'hésite
jeu très lentes moi quand je parle en
jouant vraiment pas du tout l'habitude
et je vais tout la fuite
un coup guy est ce qu alors je pense
qu'il serait très fier gail de secours
mon but c'est juste de finir mon
développement un jour ou l'autre ce qui
me met ce qui aura un échec qui
s'élançait pas très grave j'ai quand
même manger ashes toujours dangereux
inutiles et là je vais jouer 5
j'aurai une idée de fou et 5
il peut faire un échec mais c'est juste
un échec
je ne pas tomber quand je regarde pas du
tout attendu à force de parler je menace
une enfilade est ici est que vous vous
plus suis assez serein après avoir
transpiré à grosses gouttes f5
je vais manger à chis j'ai un fouet un
fonds de plus devrait bien se passer
j'ai pouvoir va bien arrêtée à 100%
attention à pas le terme à terre trop la
classe g 8
si peu de téléporter sato ont su réagir
à chaud j'ai joué à 6b saint-louis si
vous n'êtes pas trop de problèmes ouais
je reviendrai à vis de faire anthony
serait de voir ce que tu me disais je
suis pas sûr d'avoir compris le moment
est exact ouais ça se passe d'un jardin
y'a que ça va j'ai passé si l'on voit à
la caméra les gouttes sur mon front et
je peux vous assurer qu'elle plombe et
relais bon champion l'a mangé les six
attention alors sous contrôle ici
maîtrise son sujet enfin il fait
semblant
j'ai quand même essayé de le mater assez
vite
ah ça y est c'est bon j'ai plein de gaz
pour mouroir au bal trompette ce baobab
bataille la raison j'aimerais bien le
malt est comme ça mais il veut pas
réussir à se cacher bon donc si je vais
essayer quand même d'investir la seconde
rangée la c2 les petits mâles du couloir
et j'essaie de faire un petit piège à
base de u6 baisse de 2,4 pardon je
laisse manger c'est pas grave je
mangerai y six mois si me mangeras mat
du couloir donc il va juste devoir
reculer avec son fou il peut y manger ce
pion derrière tu pas fait attention pas
dramatique
j'ai du foot français 3 qui existe un
tour à deux mais je vais quand même
enlevé nos fous qui est attaqué il ya
défendu la casa 2 donc du coup ça
marchait plus
à un parti où il va aider à la fin je
vais pas prendre le risque d' appuyer
sur match suivant ja beaucoup trop
transpirer dans cette partie et oui je
joue aussi j'ai su repartir à se serrer
kg 6 pi g7 joue exactement ce que j'ai
un divers-gauche blitz je veux revenir
un peu en arrière du coup parce que vous
vouliez voir un truc pas c'est qu'au
début on avait vraiment l'impression que
je pouvais gagner une pièce il avait un
petit peu court en l'air donc je sais
pas à quel moment une extrêmement pas
ici jouer cavalier f5
c'était beau à merci ça me touche
beaucoup dont phil à haouidja rappelé
par dan f4 variable prod émotions trop
de pression directe vous à chis gagner
la dame fait j'étais obnubilé par ce
cavalier c'est comme ça en fait on rate
des trucs évident typiquement c'est quoi
quand on pense vraiment un telle
tactique on joue pour quelque chose et
du coup au lieu de garder tous les
horizons ouverts juste j'ai bloqué en
fait je me suis dit il ya une surcharge
sur ces pièces et j'étais tellement
concentrée sur la diagonale la grande à
grateloup que j'ai oublié fois chic et
élémentaire salut boom des gaz
enfin pour c'est la page audience tape
complètement récupère à peu durer le
plaisir
c'était plus élégant cavaliers de cisco
et puis en fait juste je voulais pas
donner mon foot race noire
vous étiez un futur bouquet tout je le
garde quoi qu'il arrive c'est ma pièce
fétiche même pour une dame se voit pas
ça peut ressembler à certaines
structures des fois aussi à des
françaises comptent mais sauf avec
affrontions de kate ou quoi et donc tu
as raison à anthony complètement les
dames c'est de la merde voilà c'est ça
le foot est beaucoup plus fort et fois
çi ce marché l'a fait j'ai raté on va
regarder une partie entre 2 juin qui
sera certainement de bien meilleure
qualité
on n'a pas quito paquito que notre
relish à qui tous contre un riche qu'est
ce que ça donne
[Musique]
voit cependant un procès à nous parler
évidemment des dames des tablas de la
pièce des chacals chine sur le lien bah
écoutez je suis pas sûr je doive être
félicitée pour ses parties ou remercier
même un tour tout qui vient d'être
oubliée de l'impression et oui c'est
contagieux apparemment l'époque était la
contagion malheureusement acquis
tournages télé très acide tu cours dans
apparemment eu le temps de voir ce qui
se passait qui qui mènent ces barbarian
qui est légèrement en tête justement
paquito était second si je suis pas allé
voir dans deux personnes
taquin onctueux les la 46e je l'avais
pas vu il affronte dragon's haut la
fronde dans l'agglo dans une position
assez plate quand même faut bien dire
ici du coup c'est de toi en fait car une
seule dose soit de chasse comme la
trompette le bal
j'ai oublié le mélange des deux tu as le
droit quand même battre le droit mais
ont tenu mais perso je préfère garder
mon goût le fou du puy en ghetto jab et
jordan ok ben écoute tu m'as fait des
frayeurs
alors
ici lui juste essayé de mettre la
pression c'est normal les champs vers la
colonne dames c'est pas dramatique on
pourra jouer bercy selon peer pour
l'instant qu'à montueux qui est assez
solide avec les blancs contre un jour
avec 100 points de plus que lui va voir
s'ils arrivent à se montrer un peu
créatif autant que dans le choix du
pseudo à gagner dragon's on l'a vu tout
à l'heure dans une partie hachée plus ce
qui s'est passé je crois que c'est lui
qui était complètement gaillot qu'on me
pourrit poupe et qui a craqué c'est pas
que je peux en train de lui porter la
poisse
alors il prend son temps qu'à comme tu
hockey et lycées tour tranquillement où
il va certainement aussi de doubler sur
la colonne f
ce genre de pollution quand même très
calme où les deux joueurs ont essayé de
se battre pour l'un des cinq l'autre des
quatre et dans tous les cas on fait le
chorégraphe pourra toucher à rien aux
contres et du coup il se passera pas
grand chose et non j'ai pas d'origine
libanaise pierrot pas seulement de ça
par rapport à mon prénom pense pas avoir
le temps particulièrement battre par
contre malheureusement d'ailleurs
d'entrée nom vient de ma mère qui est
même beaucoup l'acteur sami frey s'est
pas d'autres générations
je crois que c'est pas samy naceri je
vous rassure tout de suite prêt nous
vient principalement de la whey ça
merci ça q games là ça me choque heures
comme sabine je mords de chaque français
est connu que les grands maîtres ça me
choque heures je crains de ne pas avoir
la richesse c'est salue la série un faux
pas qui se décrivent comme ça part comme
mon créneau mais ses passes à venir
c'est sûr ça me dit quelque chose
est ce que tu fais en sommes mais je ne
viens pas tout de suite j'ai pu donc
ouais c'est sûr que je vois quand même
ça s'embrouille dans ma tête trop
d'échecs
ça me choque heure du coucher unique et
grand maître et je sais pas de cadeau il
est français mais les thèmes d'origine
et je dire une grosse connerie donc je
parlais à dire j'allais dire égyptienne
je sépare au fait il a exactement
management semble dans les catégories
jeunes les plus dé l'ol est pas cuba
depuis va bien bien la table est devenu
grand maître sega l'égyptienne je dis
pas de bêtise est très sympa ça me
choque heure voit plus trop aux échecs
je suis passé d'un petit peu arrêter un
joueur talentueux en tout cas est ici
cas quand on tue et qui malheureusement
c'est un petit peu fait actifs y est et
son roi se retrouve affaibli et ça
devient difficile après c'est pas si
claire ou encore plus que parfois il
peut utiliser les colonnes pour attaquer
maintenant qu'aucun qui leur avait prévu
car je pense que c'est bien de jouer
waouh
c'est généralement bien deux secondes m
leroy ou juin pour permettre justement
cet échec intermédiaires et au retour
j'ai 2 et du courage et 2 je pense que
c'est pas très précis et il se retrouve
avec avec même cas pour moi finalement
donc peut-être pas si dramatique ce qui
arriva qu'incombe tu veux voir ma canne
falloir qu'ils contractent un pur pour
son roi dans cette position
force de l'amitié du joug beaucoup mieux
le cheshire ouais c'est une arme assez
de la jouer un tour à 6 c'est malin en
tout cas je trouve il va passer sa tour
de ce côté là pour attaquer mais
peut-être r5 et kaka montueux qui
pourrait stabiliser l'état de son
estomac dans cette position voilà on a
interdit un petit peu l'ouverture autour
de son roi et bataille adam franchise
alors là faut pas le rater ça peut être
un peu une explosion de saveurs du cac40
tu as dame prend 1,6 avec tout rejet de
derrière il rentrait donc extrêmement
favorable il l'a pu et quand monsieur
qui est en train de quoi mettre le
pauvre dragon's aux rebelles à 6,1 et
hassan qui va tomber
manger le pion par contre final four
manger les choses du coup c'est être la
grosse perte pour kaka onctueux et très
très chaud ici
et attention ils mangent les pions
peut-être un peu trop
c'est bien de les pousser c'est ce que
fait de ragonneau d'un compris c'est
dommage dommage la preuve de techniques
en finale
est ce que maintenant il a placé ses
atouts pour devenir complètement hors
jeu et les pions loire va avancer tout
seul alors qu'à la base c'est d'abord un
blocus en jeu revenir dès que ce sera
fini mais normalement avec les blancs
ils étaient gagnants si on a tous un
vide qui force le malin toi invite
encore une fois tout rachiki manager 2
essais matin par able du coup babel
cac40 yeux ça c'est encore terminé de
manière à gastrique j'ai envie de dire
alors
en arrière si dans cette finale a
beaucoup qui est très important il
aurait dû jouer à tout prix - h 4 pour
empêcher le roi noir de prendre
l'initiative et d'arrivée ou soutien de
ses pions là c'était vraiment très très
important et la tour ensuite aurait une
plus en pouvoir rattraper le plonger
du coup google instant arrivants g5
s'est terminée parce que on a pu le voir
les pions lié selon eux trop fort ça
c'est vraiment dommage hein pour
quelqu'un de dieu c'est un petit peu la
perte d'une vie c'est la catastrophe
alors est-ce que je peux revenir un peu
en arrière la cavalier sur le roi ouais
je peux pas ici par khune
bien que battu par géoles un viol c'est
un fort joueur ah oui oui je vois
qu'alain cavalier h trois fourchettes
dabbachi peut être ici 8 on était comme
ça oui au lieu des 4 effectivement
damages qui c'était le bon groupe le roi
est obligé d'aller aux clients et les
cavaliers h3 très fort anthony en fait
tu vois toutes les tactiques et derrière
vous pouvez gagner à gagner la qualité
donc c'était la bonne suite tu as raison
la raison n'a barbarian qui est toujours
en tête
alors qu' on va aller voir l on à
balanod verte contre cirilo
la garde comme cyril lourd je crois que
la banane ici est mûr il a juste deux
pions parce alliés soutenus par ces fous
a pas de problème il devrait gagner
assez facilement chez attractive et puis
moi je reste au passage me manquer il
veut juste jouer t3 sont avec les bombes
n'aura pas d'autre choix que de donner
un coup de fouet pour les deux chocs à
ces impératifs
moi j'aurais bien aimé jouer quatre pour
au moins sauver ce pion et il veut pas
il veut pas donné ok mais la défense
passive est vouée à l'échec
il doit être recyclé
par contre assez dommage je tire wade de
on est il était un petit peu négligents
m'a averti les objets de chasse et son
fou peut-être on va par du mal ensuite à
progresser ici et les pions ou mettre en
danger et il pouvait s'en sortir
par contre avec le roi f4 j'y crois pas
du tout
6 à partir de 19h tu mets un lien si
vous voulez oui à toutes les infos sur
le format ça se joue en
sept gagnants et des mini cette panne et
stade de tennis 17 de trois parties je
crois et je crois plus 0 fable iii ainsi
entre autres maxime et qui avait un
autre et mathieu etienne feront un match
le complet ressemble sont les demi
finales pour rappel la finale aura lieu
demain à demain soir
il galère
il a perdu un de ses deux pions et joue
très très vite là deux minutes cinq ans
c'est normal qu'ils soient pas hyper
précis ah oui là en fait l'avancé des
deux bannières un peu l onctuosité du
coup il s'est fait manger son making
oui on a encore un mais le roi blanc et
quand même centralisée elle vient
difficile à gagner pour balade verte
sirigu qui a peut-être sauvé le demi
point de manière tahkout tueuse
exactement boom dégage alors j'ai si je
pense que c'est très bien ça crée un
autre jeu potentiel sur le pion g qui
peut être dangereux il peut les défendre
avec son endroit 25 c'est le bon coup
ici n'ont pas trop le choix il peut pas
perdre structure voilà web 5 s'est joué
je vois pas comment gagner que les noirs
parce que sur foi de vous les trois
roues revient quatre notre fou trouve
pas une case pour menacer d'accompagner
le bureau c2 et s'il va trop a essayé de
venir au soutien
il y avait parfois le fil rouge et 7
il y aura un gros contre jeu avec le
pion gêne je trouve ça très beau
sauvetage de cyril ou voilà ils répètent
les coups alors attrait balade vers
tahiti va tourner pareil que fable il y
perd tout le temps la pendule d'eric h
15 minutes le temps d'inscrire se
trouvent deux feuilles sur la feuille de
match
est ce vrai alors je pense que fable vie
contrairement à nous a pas besoin de
vérifier l'orthographe de son nom avant
de l'écrire
du coup c'est pas si long que ça avec
moi à chaque fois que je fais un post
ce book j'aime du coup je mets fab fab
libye et quand je suis courageux je mets
le nom en entier mais mais ça vous
prendre autant de peuples de posté
l'article
on n'a pas vu la simplification l'avenir
parce que je pensais qu'avec les blancs
ils pouvaient juste de toucher à rien du
coup c'est bizarre il a fait froid des 3
pts est il arrivé aux le droit des
quatre câbles très logique pour prendre
position
n'empêche le roi de passer c'est très
étonnant elle est juste d'être
du coup maintenant le pion à tomber doit
être un nouveau gagnant mais agissent là
deux gagnants je pensais que les fous
même couleur surtout en blitz presse pas
si facile le tournoi de ce soir stéphane
c'est une coupe au pubis trine mais que
les caritatives aux médecins sans
frontières comment ce directe en demi
finale
l'idée c'est vraiment de de faire un
truc un peu à être visuel situation
actuelle de bastiani soirée sympa il y
aura des foires anthouard il y aura du
beau jeu pas facile à battre
il a quand même réussi à revenir faire
barrage avec ce droit vous n'arrive pas
à contourner
à retenir la nullissime est ok l'as
cannes 15 secondes contre 2 minutes 40
fou j'ai passé une décision alice 9 de
cyril ou parce qu'ils créent un pion pas
ses protégés aucun signal de ravel et
garrigues de maliens enfantine pour
balade merde très heureux balade verte
ici l'échangé de fou alors qu'a priori
ils pouvaient pas passer les finales de
rois mages n'a rien pour moi il ya un
pion pas assez protégé à 0 à 99 9 % du
temps travaillé ici donc c'est vraiment
un choix très très étrange
en sachant que les noirs ne progresse de
progresser pas à parler je tournais
attend avec les blancs de toute façon
fait blocus d'atouts et défendu les
plans adverses avant spa vous g6
incompréhensible pour moi tu sais aucun
très bons joueurs donc c'est pas parce
qu'il s'est passé la fatigue
qu'est-ce qu'on va regarder
j'ai vu la grosse purge or j'avais lu la
grosse la grosse prunes
c'est la grosse planche en fait j'étais
un petit peu biaisé par kaka bout car
non tu es pardon j'enchaîne les lapsus
du coup contre gorale 25
on a vu plusieurs fois le joueur belge
la grosse purge ma grosse purge mois sa
position mais également de la grosse
pointure case noire s'est un peu troué
de partout et là quelques cases blanches
quand même pour compenser mes cavaliers
en d6 va trouver un avant poste
extrêmement prometteur disent qu'ils
vont pouvoir ils ont ramené un autre au
cas où je pense
très dur à jouer pour les noirs cette
position peut-être que la grosse purge
de s'auto infligé son pseudo ouais
malheureusement ça marche pas comme ça
l'association des joueurs je dois me
l'ait contraint ne serait pas un big
lots pour autant limite mois les jours à
tour de rôle les limites du droit à deux
petites embrouilles plus qu'autre chose
genre le main cerveau par exemple vous
avez déjà dû en voir de temps en temps
c'est très difficile c'est amusant mais
je pense qu'on ne perde pas mal de force
brute que le joueur ne réfléchissent pas
pareil vous parler même si des groupes
trop d'heures qui nous fait sa petite
délation quotidienne ici
ccp 33 l'accusé aujourd'hui
alors je vois bien quel est absent gül
en s'associant fin oui lombale même
style en plus c'est sur ces mots ans
aimants et du coup la grosse purge que
c'est quand même un petit peu de son en
sortir qui ont une triple menace sauf
qu'ils ajustent d'amd 2 voilà tout
simplement qui défend tous terminés on
va dire le développement et on est très
heureux
exclamations des six à risques d'au très
bien se passer pour les morts il faut en
descente c'est un gros pions dans la
journée position ferme et les cavaliers
sont largement supérieurs au fou voire
sont les pièces d'eau millions de sujets
que le jour où des blancs n'est pas
inintéressant ces diagonales même s'il
n'est pas extraordinaire donc lure s'il
faut jouer aller oui je n'ai pas fait
attention et double attaque groupe
bekaert à leurs forces et aux non non ça
parle droit gorale la part le droit de
donner ton cavaliers monstrueux contre
un sou dégueulasse il a pas d'autre
groupe h
donc je suis outré tout ça pour manger
une qualité ont plus non il ya une telle
différence de valeur entre ces deux
pièces pascal a lyon des 6es sous x en
bessin juste alors je comprends et
n'ayez pas derrière le flanc j'exagère
mais cet échange aurait il encore
certainement gains en sièges
mais quand même cellou trad à droite en
lieu sûr qui a fait un match incroyable
une fois que six états parties et
terminé c'est vraiment galère pour
retrouver mes cd partie arménienne
le format est pas hyper un fait pour
alors si jamais tu appartiens pas encore
maté ou être trouvé mais malheureusement
c'est pas le cas je te vois pas ouais
c'est vraiment galéré mais très heureux
pour toi le futur j'aurais bien aimé
voir la base du cou ouais tu peux mettre
le lien dans le chat pour les gens parce
que ce que je peux te retrouver la
partie comme ça s'est passé pendant ce
temps non stop pendant ce temps david
armand voilà il appuyait que les blancs
voilà je suis de tout cas et grosses
pioche ici les blancs mérite d'être puni
ou pour outrage à magistrat de le don du
cas là les couples fout là c'était juste
mais mme kirilow et pas après quoi jean
vous tient évidemment la qualité bas on
se rend compte qu il la récupère pas
continuer il a deux capitaines mans à la
grosse purge mais il s'appelle la grosse
purge vous des qualités c'est pas très
grave il aurait cavale qui est hyper
puissant le couple dame cavaliers très
très fort aux échecs live à mater y
avait eu 3 samada ce matin par deux
partout c'est dommage qu'il fasse
cavalier 3 ici la grosse purge
allez c'est normal c'est naturel ou veut
mater et de f1 voilà la grosse purge qui
va mater en g2 les chorales mais je paye
le prix de son coup guy esque de pully
il est depuis
hélas une douzaine de minutes et ça
c'est vraiment un truc hyper important
dans vos parties
quand vous avez une pièce très très
puissante n'allez pas à l'échanger
contre une pièce adverse c'est le rêve
de votre adversaire
aucune classe adverse qui ne fait rien
même si c'est pour griller un petit peu
de matériel juste soulager sa position
donc privilégier la dynamique aux
décisions de bassement matérialistes
encore plus envie d'ailleurs et
barbarian qui a fait le trou avec 16 sur
18 devant in à être vives lui et balades
vertes est assez le bon mc alger le
droit qui est qui est pas mal
aujourd'hui
pakito est là qu est ce qu on va
regarder la partie de joueurs un peu
moins bien classés et pète charrie un
petit big three mieux contre jambon
beurre on voit souvent l'ami sandwich
qui il ya une pièce de moi qu'est ce qui
s'est passé et ce qui s'est passé jambon
beurre qui s'est oublié là c'est à dire
que c'est le mauvais sandwich sandwich
avec beaucoup trop de moutarde
sous ce fou ou la liaison avec la dame
et du coup c'est la pièce gratuite
annonce qu'elle autoroute pour pépé de
charry normalement il a échangé son fou
qui a été mangé une pièce on va voir
c'est intéressant aussi
il arrive à conclure sa propre banque ça
part plutôt bien ils attaquent le roi
l'a pas de faiblesses sans doute
la nasse ça j'ai jamais testé sa manière
de très mauvais goût et le pire sandwich
que vous ayez jamais mort de gestion
dites moi vous un jambon beurre avec
jean fouladou donne effectivement
l'étendard de famille de khatera on y
sera bien phu g6 pourquoi pas pouvoir
défendre le plus bref centre problème du
faux problème c est cavalier g6 ou alors
juste repartir offert un petit piège
avec une fourchette
jouer sur le clouage tout cas pour
l'instant il est chaud pp de chareil une
exploite parfaitement les erreurs de son
adversaire
il analyse sur les pizzas là c'est la
faute de goût une teen je garde bien
d'accord s'enchaînèrent sont les pizzas
sucré salé la mi chèvre mi chou sar
o'shea ça c'est écoeurant
je suis créé dans la pizza et la pizza
du terek est devenu un petit peu à la
mode dont les meilleures pizzas arrière
de toutes les villes de france et les
kebabs général ils proposent souvent
l'option deezer nutella ou gaou sait
jamais hein
ce qui avait carrément biais de prendre
un pseudo cac 40 tués dans la foulée en
rentrant chez lui faire de donner des
idées
il a joué vous croit elle cède très bien
avec les petits cavaliers justice karin
et s'il a le roi recul pour rester à la
défense de bientôt il y aura juste dames
chez 8la tout retombe donc benshan il
prend son temps mais jouent tous les
meilleurs coups c'est propre à ces trois
poules dégage d'accord bien tu est mise
à l'honneur aujourd'hui
j'espère que tu renée raffy sûr que ton
pseudo attire l'attention
dams est ensuite mange 6 1 c'était
vraiment la razzia
là par contre j'ai un petit peu peur
péter pekarik joue très bien mais qui
est pas très rapide
du coup
coût pourrait bien perdre autant très
justement que jambon-beurre regagné de
manière très injuste ici hype accélérer
la cadence pipi de chat à l'ail sur bon
passons sont forts habituels du coup le
3 + 2 je sais pas ce que sinon il a
vraiment plutôt bien joué bien calculer
c'est très forte ce dob dégage des
grands maîtres du pseudo je crois à
séduire les grands maîtres quelques
valeurs seront apprend il y aura de f4
matt tel ça peut sauver des beach boys
et les huit secondes 3 et 5 est le seul
coup ici pour pas se faire ma tête
j'espérais gagner salement autant je
pense pas car celle soit y performent
pseudo aura à mon avis il est plutôt
sous la barre des 1000 lots en pseudo
je pense ils font son nom à chaque fois
la pub
seconde alors même si un avantage
matériel et kraton avec 1,5 kg ont passé
les deux plus tard ils pas tous les
jours et on va voir s'ils arrivent à
jouer sur ces deux secondes jusqu'au la
sphère acquiert un peu ça pourrait être
la panique lier du d4 du dam g7 allait
tourner trois c'est bien mais déjà
attention je vois les réseaux de vol
arrivé le roi s'est un peu affaibli il
joue à chaque fois avec moins d'une
seconde son coin la tour first 4 très
très peur pour piper de shary boyle fait
de la merde surtout d'un point de vue
pratique ouest est acquis mais septies
par ici info juste s'occuper du roi
essayé d'échanger et voilà la prophétie
se réalise et les perdants après avoir
même largement dominé sur l'échiquier
mais ici c'est du blitz du coup tant pis
pour lui il ya six minutes barbarian et
la rage l'avant ce qui va gagner c'est
de regarder c'est pas mal un petit
gambie roi ou plus de mots greffe aulaye
arjol voir du beau jeu
ah oui il allait bien je mets un éclair
le beau jeu était là c'est dur c'est dur
de perdre autant comme ça mais c'est
encourageant en tout cas sur sa façon de
jouer a beaucoup
et fall avec des soutiens maugrée
volailles dans georges cheveux
qu'environ envie de le soutenir
mouiller le maillot
metz
tiens bas 16 lambie roi malheureusement
jamais changé les dames généralement
c'est pas le but
et l'initiative allait pour les noirs
ici le futur 4 est quand même assez fort
le pion f4 est très mal placé il bloque
dans pièce même le recul et wave ii
s'était autorisé
bonjour d'opposition j'ai passé arrive
souvent de vous dire davantage à ma bien
qu l'émotion on n'a jamais le droit
boîte une règle entendu tellement de
nouveaux concepts un peu
abracadabrantesque jamais entendu ce
truc de reculer le pion nouvelle
variante des échecs
pour encore plus de force aux pions je
pense ce serait intéressant car il
pourrait pas logés en arrière c'est trop
le bordel mais juste reculé
ouais là ça change de toutes les
théories ça m'arrangerait du coup
il voit qu'il a du mal à se développer
sur trois c'est une vraie épine dans
cette dans sa position
retourner ans plutôt bien joué mais
après ça peut vite se retourner même
s'il est noir sont objectivement mieux
jean rampon le plus beau la structure
pour détériorer malgré tout et puis on a
trois qui est très forte aussi tombé
dans l'absolu donc mauvais fallait comme
encore toutes ses chances
mais pour la souffrance mais non c'est
pas catastrophique
le problème c'est vraiment la rive pas
pour l'instant à activer ces pièces là
on peut jamais mangé 11 3 parce qu'il ya
le clouage perdrait la pièce attention à
ça et du coup exorbitants un pion pour
enfin se libérer du joug bambi roi donc
les pions c'est pas grave d'avoir les
douanes est ce qui compte c'est
l'activité mais c'est quand même très
dangereux développions qui va arriver en
d4 sur à deux pions pas assez protégé la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on peut faire un
blocus sur gaza blanchissent il avec les
blancs donc c'est pas si clair les
blancs sont bâle carbon mai mais c'est
pas si facilement parce qu'on n'avance
pas et qu'une option b 5e j'aime pas
j'aurais pu jouer à ça qu'on fait ce que
la colonne en plus strictement rien en
faire pas que ce soit très utile et
menace le 2 des 4 x 4 hockey fo est
simple c'est pas mal ça va quand même
créé un petit blocus sa défense
alors tu es tombé du g5 pour
déstabiliser tout ça il y aura juste g3
j'imagine ou encore la gagner avec les
noirs c'est pas facile
[Musique]
bravo renault sa lune risque arrive sur
le tard bien joué il a à z pas combien
tu as terminé dans les premiers voiliers
une tour qui s'est échangé une paire de
tours a toujours un petit plomb de moins
pour les blancs mais il s'en sort pas si
mal maugrey fallen
comme je vous le disais il arrive quand
même un peu à créer un blocus
esquennoy j'aimerais bien essayer de
jouer des cas trois des cinq tours ces
six là bas but ça l'a pas vu serge
eyrolles et maintenant attention il n'y
a pas des matisse est tout à fait 6 3 et
4h trois ronds dans la dernière minute
je vois chaque 3 g can quoi il prend la
découverte sur échec
maintenant le pion âge qui devient très
très dangereux c'est très très chaud
cette finale sont tous les résultats
sont possibles qu'avec les beaux il a
bien retourner maintenant tour g7 où
j'essaie de salaire de faire le taf ici
je vois pas comment va arrêter de tout
âge ont ensuite à l'ewi maugrée volaille
qui restent qui laisse pas passer la
chance c'est dommage argent ils avaient
quand même fait une bonne partie juste
cette infiltration de la tour sur la
6ème orange et leur a été fatal et
angéla qui propose nul
[Musique]
il est très mal en fait
la 56 secondes et il restait sept
secondes dans le tournoi du coup du come
on révolte qui aura retourner la partie
juste pour l'odeur l'aura pas à ça le
rap a rapporté le point
ouais t'as vu une brèche s'est engouffré
dedans dans la 6e auront géré mais cette
fameuse 1 que les partis ne vont pas
jusqu'au bout et on a terminé
donc merci à tous vous étiez quasiment
100 j'ai marqué deux points
j'ai participé et c'est pas barrière
d'un quai regagné 19 sur 21 km assez
largement devant djs deuxième 1651 qui
est un gros tournoi
bravo à lui quel jeu le droit dans le
top10 aussi kevala yens du coup cgem lui
souille quatrième au pied du podium
et là vous êtes brookwood de vraiment un
classement après moi j'ai 100 % je suis
le seul joie peut-être le seul joueur à
100% par cela d'autres qu'on fait qu'une
seule partie ne sait pas donc je m'en
vais invaincu et du coup bah je vous
incite à bien très nombreux ce soir à
partir de 19h je vais vous remettre le
lien il était déjà là ok je pense ça va
être vraiment sympa merci d'ide et merci
pour nous à pas ag des grosses cattin
sur une partie ça va très haut il ya
confus qui me dit dans la foulée alors
j'ai pas encore mangé quelqu'un tu eu
même si ton pseudo mais pas forcément
d'humeur à le faire je vais quand même
bien appeler mais on pourra viser à un
autre moment si tu veux bien sûr ce sera
sur sur twitter j'aime les liens à
chaque donc il ya toutes les infos
dessus sera sur twizz blisstree une
chaise com fr pour sa part mme mongeon
boom dégage ça passe encore j'essaie de
delà des mots servent de toutes ses
qualités
et moi je vous remercie tous
du coup je vous dis à très vite ce soir
et demain au ciri encore le rendez vous
dimanche à 13h02
voilà passer une bonne après mme ciao
voilà en tout ont ponctué c'était
exactement boom negash c'est le mot de
la fin je vais rester là dessus